hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play da attic part 1 [ __ ] you door
oh yeah my way your deck might as well
start testing keys now vol hi miss uh
okay so we got a key to the main storage
area where all the lowdown is being
stored wasn't this way nope nope there
was a weird shovel lever but nothing but
it um the dual rear oh no way woah oh
hello my citadel silt might smite
citadel my Syracuse how could I let
myself be banished by ancient pail
pellet pet pal last said tell ozzie
guillen if this is like quotes from a
poem I don't know it Pulaski ins I have
no idea oh no it's another dead body
oh no it's so scary I'm so worried about
that Wow
got it this is a storage room Derek for
the love of God do not end up like your
mother shut up
you said your own voice wrong Rosy's go
Derek for the love of God don't become
your mother
but the last and only time Derrick stay
out of my research okay
all right that's that's it for public
but luckily I have part two right here
so watch this oh I'll read this I'll do
my monologue once I get done with part
two because there's only part two it out
at the moment there it is chapter two so
there's only chapter two out at the
moment so let me finish this up yeah
chapter two by Seth one four six six and
jetliners eggs eggs after the horrific
experience derek faced in an attempt to
get to his basement for safety safety
then why should it his father be angry
at him if he's just trying to be safe oh
wait he went up to the attic oh yeah
that's right he finds himself confused
everything theme seems the way back to
what it should be
he gets up off the floor and calmed
himself down and thence lead to the
worst and he is forced to go to go to
the nearby village for help Derek then
finds out his father's terrible work did
not stop at his home it spread over to
the nearby villages as well now he must
go and save anyone in the village from
the monsters if they don't find him
first
hahahaha start OOP good way oh oh oh
okay
my chillax lantern hello
anything in there Wow I am totally
bribing on Oh
Oh way too much acid of the Damned man
maybe don't get that you weren't paying
attention to the few videos ok sanity
potion alright better now better oh no
scary footprints wait this is where I
was wasn't it
listen this where I was this looks like
the same base what why oh there's a
freaking cockroach going across my
screen what death wow look at that thing
what okay it faded away alright I think
I've ever seen that before oh yeah this
is the same place but that basement is
different now storage area isn't so big
and it's awfully brightly lit in here I
mean it's like crazy bright but aren't I
supposed to eat like a village or
something no no no what's going on I'm
so confused I'm so confused
whoa what what whoa take me my body is
ready okay
I expected that was faking are you let's
review
whoa yeah buried it in the wall okay
yeah there's the same same same just
wave writer it's like way brighter
brighter than I've ever seen okay
there's and this is different to this
was a dungeon with a dead body in it
maybe Derrick's going crazy
you think Derek's a little crazy do ye
danda box get out of the way uh I'm just
gonna check everything cuz I'm out of
the supplies I had I've got oil supply
yeah this room was full of bodies and
this was library
okay so far nothing looks too weird
well that was open before to the strange
altar room whatever that was did Derek's
dad swing on in and almost miss that and
change everything the whole layout got
clean up the bodies all right nothing
can stand in the way of science right
there was not broken things seem down
right normal that looks the same oh
hello anybody home our dear old Papa
Ellis is his name I think up these are
birds master Matt [ __ ] your [ __ ] dad are
you I'm rebelling I'm being rebellious
I'm an individual nope
can I go up to the attic again nope all
right I guess I gotta go back where I
started on that balcony probably it's a
whole symbolic circle of level design
whatever hello hello you know no not
even a tinderbox
hello there's nothing in these drawers
ever I don't know why I bother checking
hello hello new potted plant
that's back up I felt I fell I fell
right into a loading screen
I liked inside better
I liked inside a lot better hello girls
here I liked inside a lot better
oh that hey don't be like that I now
play nice thank you sign that read
yourself in a strange language
Declan atio fluke 'some aqua Chloe okay
yep that was words
I'm assuming this is me why that's how I
walk why why are you looking at me so
weird
doesn't everybody walk like this hello
ah whoa probably just stay on the path
bric-a-brac you I'll go where oh wow
go this is a tiny house this isn't even
a house why do I live in a big mansion
while other people are suffering with
[ __ ] like this they don't even have a
kitchen they don't even have a bathroom
in here this is a Shack this isn't a
house
and besides I'll stray off the path if I
wanna you told me you're not the boss
and me let's just say construction area
please Bay back 200 feet
[ __ ] the police oh come on
what the hell what a screw you kick away
near water pump pump into wall order
screw you
ah damn it that's that [ __ ] it's one
of those two stacks can't go in there
nope oh there we go freedom daisies kick
okay good making good kick that's some
kind of hard eating cake I suppose
making it as hard huh [ __ ] I can break
I'm gonna break it I want to break it so
bad I want to break it let me break it
give me something to break it with oh I
can't break whatever that monsters
thought they're probably validly
what happened it is a village is this
like Resident Evil Silent Hill deal
going on here yeah he's gone anyway
strand off the path oh yeah
oh there's anything like evaluating
these houses
oil I guess that's good a dead dog
lovely of all your meager possessions
you just had to have a dead dog
good for you congratulations I suppose
that's priority all strand off the path
City Hall all the evacuation plans when
we moved in pointed here in times of
need not sure if anyone else is around
what who's saying that was that there's
another mansion whatever I need to
explore town one there's got to be more
stuff here like an easter egg or some
point of the story or a key that I'm
supposed to get this awfully big town it
was just nothing I'd be kind of
disappointed weights this up same place
I was in says isn't it I'm turning a
circle either that they all look the
same and they have nothing in them
probably that one come on bring it on oh
oh hello there you are again that's the
same one okay so this is like a circle
all right I'll just go into the big
figure
well you chasing me ah you still see me
on all there is is their common is it
comin
nope on the door anyone who needs to
enter the city hall we have stashed the
key in the abandoned house oh crap
at the end of the long path
please go retrieve it if you were
shattered oh crap crap crap crap crap
ever you ah well you know that Bush oh
my face gave me a high-five to the face
why did you do that
okay B I'm guessing the house aw crap
miss me
Oh God get in here
nope I just need to get in one of these
I was in losing I just run I'll run I'm
a running Oh down
was it in here where did he come out of
ah how do you get there
courier take a barrel to the thanks bomb
[ __ ] oh yeah
okay I'm finding house to be into the
long I don't even know know where that
I didn't even see where this guy came
from whatever
I'm guessing if I had to guess who'd be
the same house that this guy came in
from that would be my guess
my guess see of course the abandoned
house has a monster in it because that
just makes sense all right whatever all
right whatever at the end of the long
path yep okay um not that way there I
can't even deviate out of the path I'll
sit don't block me with an invisible
wall this path is pretty long where'd
you come from what where grave get away
oh it don't look good
it's the abandoned house yep
hello finally my Lord has sent his
minions to cleanse the village of these
sinners Thank You O Lord O Lord this is
still the science cult I don't know but
I'm actually out of time for now thank
y'all so much for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next part bye-bye